it's a deeply personal film I have many
ideas within that for whatever reason
there hadn't been able to execute I felt
was important to really see the
Wolverine that I knew and felt and I got
to know in over 17 years so I would have
done anything but I was stubborn to the
head of the studio said to another night
well I finally got to know stubborn Hugh
James Mangold who I asked to do this
picture we developed it together I
thought the studio would say not but
they didn't they said yes emphatically
what I'm proud about is that movie it
was very close to what we set out to do
it's a volunteer but it's a film about
the ramifications upon us it is an
action film but also it's a film of our
family that moves you
[Music]
don't say no you can't make that movie
we were trying to do something that was
different from all the other x-men
movies including the title it doesn't
say Wolverine up there we make a movie
about a man not about sabirah we didn't
want to have 15 different mutants with
powers and lots of green screen and huge
sort of visual effects there's no X Jets
there's no mansions it's these three
superheroes with fading powers on a road
trip and a beat-up limo it's a very
different type of mood
there were things I wish I could have
done until this movie you know if we
could have just got Halle Berry back in
there somewhere
[Laughter]
but know that this movie is everything I
wanted it to be oh by the way we did try
at some point to get the yellow and blue
spandex suit in there some way well some
people are angry and I keep wanting to
say tell me how to do it we tried we
couldn't come up with a way to make him
cool and badass in yellow and blue
spandex
[Music]
Patrick was always in the movie the girl
character that came in after about it
eight months of us developing the script
that was where we also not really took
off I really wanted to get saber-tooth
in there somewhere again because Lia was
so great in that character but in the
end les was important I knew it had to
be smaller in some ways
we train together all right photos I
have of the two of us where our bodies
look exactly our arm position running
it's astonishing to me when we would go
and train training for the fights I
talked about the down there looking up
through the eyebrows this is how I do it
and we thought that was really important
no I'll sit on the set I'm done it
doesn't feel like I'm leaving I feel I'm
still at the dinner table but I'm just
not cooking and cleaning up anymore it's
nice but it's time for someone else to
go and do the heavy lifting literally
heavy lifting
but now a woman does get a chance to
play with the Avengers well I always
thought that would have been cool
[Music]
I've got about a month left on a movie
musical which is as a character playing
PT Barnum the greatest showman is the
opposite of this character so I'm very
excited and then I'm open I have no idea
what is it
[Music]
it was emotional it was calm a good
feeling I knew I made the right decision
and when I saw the film I was so
relieved because I really it's the last
time I knew there was not another chance
there was no safety net and I wanted
this to be a love letter to those fans
who supported me and the character over
all these years and I hope someone else
comes along and soon them and crushes it
because I think it's a great character
and deserves to have many different
interpretations